Luke conspiracy first of all I get upset
when a train crashes because there's no
reason for that oh that's right wait
what train are we thinking about like
people running trains talk about the
train that didn't happen on any of your
moms was that what you're talking about
what did you think was gonna happen when
he brought that yeah did you think it
was your mom's in any way I'm just dumb
sometimes
sometimes maybe it's a conspiracy maybe
you wanted him to bring it up I don't
know
I don't know okay so basically there's
these three train crashes in America
there should never be a train crash ever
you're a New York and you hate a train
running late
getting stuck in New York though all the
time they do but that doesn't make any
sense they don't crash they don't bang
into one another never crash there's one
road there's no reason you should crash
it's one road
another train is coming what if a bolt
comes loose then what what do you mean a
bolt comes loose yeah that shouldn't
yeah
this is a locomotive flying uh shouldn't
get loose you literally have one rail to
work on yeah have you not seen how they
make the railroads the train is spinning
like this bro that's a wheel and you
don't think a bolt on a wheel can get
loose no it's just a wheel bruh it just
goes on it yeah I didn't realize that
it's locked in place everything's good
Florida yeah you don't see Wheels fall
off of car you might see a tire versus
rubber but the metal wheels and just
spin off a car because the Bolt's not
typing Point okay so is this a terrorist
attack and we won't acknowledge exactly
because we don't want to be like yo
China
is [__] us up and I mean it's just a
little peculiar that like all three of
the trains got [__] poisonous [__] on
them like how much poison that's a great
are we send it that's a great point a
lot yeah every train got poison on it
three for three three for three wait
hold on hold on let's back it up
you're telling me that you believe the
majority of trains that are traveling in
America are traveling with poisonous
chemicals well what are you kind of
poisonous you think there's a car full
of poisonous chemicals
I think I think every train maybe hasn't
won have you ever seen a train go by
it's like mad cars have you ever been on
a train yeah
most trains are not carrying people
most trains are carrying people Mark
well of course there's a conductor holy
[__] I'm saying you see a whole train go
by it's mostly cargo and poison yeah no
yeah can we Factor I'm just the Amtrak
no Amtrak is like 10 of the trains can
you factor I don't know if you believe
that
I liked it
it's either right now and right now he's
stalling right now with the laugh he's
like I don't know if you believe that
isn't it I do not know because I thought
the same thing then I looked it up and I
was like oh I oh you thought the same
thing he's [__] on your conspiracy
theory he's like I've been there done
that but yeah I turned eight years old
and I was like oh wow not all trains
have people it's hard eight years old
that was definitely a shot yeah the fact
that he's done he thinks you're stupid
yeah yeah why do you think he's so dumb
why do you think he's stupid yeah this
is like a really [__] mean thing to
say this guy's a real that's really a
bully okay we'll go look up the
statistics
1.7 million carloads of chemicals are
shipped through America how many million
car loads are on a train every year out
of how many carloads is it more people
on trains or more chemicals I'm just
kidding there's more than 1.7 million
people taking an Amtrak every year I'll
tell you that yeah of course it's always
way more trains than people than have
chemicals it's not even close
what world do you live in where we're
just transferring chemicals all the
[__] Oh I thought we were comparing
cargo trains to passenger trains yeah
but his point is that we're doing that I
think there's more cargo but his point
oh there's way more people trains than
cargo trains all right let's see let's
look that up I don't know how to really
look that up I'm gonna look this up
already
sir
I did some research what is America it's
just a poison Factory is that what
that's what we do we just transfer
poison around everything's kind of
poison bro gasoline poisoning stop it
drink some gasoline everything drink
some gases drink some gasoline drink
some gasoline everything is poison in
that Celsius because that's Chicago
that's my point bro everything's kind of
poison argumentative everything
I don't want this argument everything is
poison I want he's he's uh literally
he's moving the gold he's moving the
[__] gold I'm just right on multiple
times help us out everything's poison
there has to be a a car and the car got
the skull with the x's on it
that's what kind of like a pirate you're
talking about Pirates It's gotta be a
pirate if it's not a pirate train then
it's not [__] police you're thinking
of a pirate train yeah I need that
I hate that old guy out that's it that's
it I also don't think 1.4 million car
loads or whatever is that much relative
to how many there are trains just
looking up that's a small percentage
Yeah but that's he's saying three train
crashes all of them three for three
poisonous material falling where the
plane crashes without poison there's a
ton they just don't report them that's
my thing so there's 1700 trained to
Romans a year yeah is not a crash that's
a crash bro but even if it's just if the
railing goes off that's right
and I want to be on your side [__] them
forever yeah so just try to say a
difference
come on well I feel like they could be
uh jacking up the statistics oh a train
uh
you can come over you can come over yeah
I mean with train stops and we gotta get
off is that not the reality
a little bit but for sure but Mark can
you figure out the information
no [__] you Google like a boomer bruh
[Laughter]
four million car loads of coal alone so
1.4 million uh poisonous [__] ain't
nothing if it's four million just oh we
are comparing cargo trains to passenger
trains yes that's what we're talking
about it
no running back
only runs through the northeastern
Corridor poison versus people I don't
want no PlayStations on a [__]
train yes you piece that is mostly
people I said it's mostly not poisoned
the original argument was this seems
like a conspiracy because why would
three crashes happen all of them got
poisoned and then you said and you guys
were like that's trains that's trains
that's not poisonous
you need to speak the [__] up Googling
five minutes
of this [__] and we never bring it up
because we're just like yeah let the
people get poisoned poison still catch
fire it was just PC and then it caught
fire why couldn't you look that up you
[__] schmuck he's on my team
what is he even Google it
is poison wood ain't poison yeah exactly
but this [__] was it's a chemical that
when it catches fire it's a chemical
that makes PVC and wind catches fire
it's very bad going off the team news
three in a row I don't know if I'm doing
it
[Music]
it just derailed it wasn't even dead it
caught fire
because he just goes yeah and none of
the [__] lights on that's what he
just did he did a knee-jerk miles
response which is what are you doing now
one episode was sitting in a [__]
dark
and Miles
he was just brown but this is a [__]
block I go miles yeah can you put the
goddamn light on our costumes that's how
the light is Google faster I don't know
what is it Google and this is
[__] you [__] Boomer bro
those who can't Google are afraid of the
truth
that's it you know I'm remixing Bill
Clinton
Google afraid of the truth
and if you're showing me what you were
looking at that's that's right there
that's the last of us
what you need to do is show how many
trains have poisoned skull bones 1.4
million Carlos miles looked that up
catches on fire is poison okay everybody
shut the [__] up Dove is talking no you
said it wasn't you gotta say something
that I like
freight trains move 2.2 million car
loads of chemicals in 2021 so that's the
most recent we don't know if the
chemicals back oh
that's horrible how would you name the
words
[Laughter]
fill it up them little kiddie pools
through a [__] clothes that's why
he's colorblind he's colorblind it was
Vinyl chloride which is a similar thing
of chlorine
I never heard anybody yell so boring but
most people travel airplanes they don't
take trains bro shut up that's a fact
look at this don't bring up another
stack and nobody arguing Freight Lines
Amtrak or [__] poison this is the
poison poison
this is definitely the poisonous map
look at that the green is poison
everything poison that's not all it's
different parts everything goes on the
same tracks as the non-poison that's not
true but I gotta separate the boys
there's passenger lines and there's
freight lines that ain't true he's wrong
there he's wrong now take that level
there are but a lot of times
what do you think is more how do you
think that there's more cargo there's
more people yeah
your face is
a girl is poison who is that where is he
on the top 50. never trust a big button
a smile Mouse never never ever I should
catch you bro
you are a big butt and a smile you are
never trust a big boy smile you know
what I'm auntie
Jesus
no you got a fat ass and a okay smart
that's crazy
it doesn't give it that nice all right
listen you have braces can we figure out
what's going on with the trains though
cause now you try to undercut the whole
[__]
animals there's a lot of chemicals being
transported I'm saying unfortunately it
is normal it's yeah unfortunately it is
normal I don't that's what does that
even how many times you see A Train
That's so vague 1700 a year how many
times have you seen I don't believe that
statistic be honest with you 1700 train
crashes a year we all know about it can
I just say five train crashes a day none
of us know yeah that was almost as a
politician don't care about me hold on
one second you think politicians will
tell them everything bro she lived hard
we I I might be a Libs listen I want to
talk about I want to talk about retards
for a second okay
we've been judging these autistic kids
for wanting to watch trains all the time
oh if it's a crash five times a day oh
oh we missing out that's their NASCAR
these [__] get to walk out the
Nascar or maybe they know something and
they're just watching the show and then
they don't tell anyone how the [__] is
every autistic kid see every plane crash
they'll never tell their mom plane crash
train crash what did I say you know what
the [__] you just said I don't know
anything
I need something to inflict pain on the
group on the group what is this guy
looking at
statistics
sick what the [__] is he looking at is
he reading the boy
unbelievable what is he doing over there
God damn it
come on
it's hard to Google this [__] oh it is
it is it isn't because they're hiding
the search yeah they're hiding the
[__] stuff I believe you're there's a
conspiracy going on there's a conspiracy
man I don't believe 1700 trained
derailments a year